I've been ready to die for many years if
the Lord was done with me so be it but
he's not you've seen the night King John
snow you know the great war still to
come you know the army of the Dead will
be upon us soon and you know I can help
you win that whoa what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another
character breakdown video once again I
am joined by gray area and today we will
be discussing Melisandre we still feel
like Melisandre has a role to play so we
wanted to give you some of our
predictions the last time we saw
Melisandre she was on Dragonstone
speaking with Varys she said she was
heading to volantis but she said she
would return in according to Melisandre
she will die in Westeros and so will
Varys so where will you go
volantis good if you don't mind my
saying I don't think you should return
to Westeros I'm not sure you'd be safe
here
I will return their Spyder one last time
m'lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you
[Music]
these are definitely some of the things
we want to talk about but first let's
discuss why Melisandre went to volantis
in the first place
gray area why do you think she went to
volantis volantis has like the biggest
red temple which is connected to the red
guy that that's where they worship the
red got it and the one in volantis is
the biggest one but they also have the
fiery hand so they could she could be
going to get the fiery hand and then
that would be crazy
cuz that's like so we have Cersei going
Yaron going to retrieve the golden
company but then we could have
Melisandre going to get the fiery hand
that's like some slave soldiers they
basically guard the temple in volantis
but she could also be going to get like
Ken Farah she must be going over there
for a reason because she told Varys she
was going to be coming back and there
would be no point in leaving unless you
had plans in volantis
Melisandre knows she is gonna die in
Westeros so she must have something to
do in volantis first and i agree with
what she said she must be going to meet
ken vara or the fiery hand personally I
would like to see Ken vore again because
she knows what Varys heard in the flames
when he was a boy Melisandre said Varys
was gonna die too so when she said she
was going to volantis I thought holy
[ __ ]
could she be going to get conveyor and
maybe can Vora plays a role in viruses
death or Melisandre that's very
interesting because that would be you
know Varys really doesn't like these
magic at all now and whatever Kim Barr
said to him that scared him like his
face looked terrified and I kind of am
of the belief that if Kim bar knows what
he heard in the flames then so does
Melisandre exactly right Melisandre must
have seen something in the flames -
otherwise how would she know Varys was
gonna
dai do you think bears with switch sides
on Daenerys though you know that's kinda
what I'm leaning towards because as of
right now Varys hasn't done anything
wrong to deserve a death sentence
Daenerys did give Varys that ultimatum
you either support me or I will burn you
to death with my dragons if you ever
betray me and of course that was when
Vera said I would expect nothing less
from the dragon queen so in order for
Varys to die I am thinking he is going
to end up betraying Daenerys unless he
would be killed by the others but I just
don't see him stepping foot on the
battlefield
whatever Varys does do that ultimately
ends up getting him killed Melisandre
must know about it and maybe she is
gonna play a role in his death because
right now their fates seem to be kind of
intertwined yeah I think I think she
knows whatever he heard in the flames
Melisandre knows Canberra knows and
whatever it was has something to do with
his role didn't the flame turn blue when
Varys heard the voice in the flames I
can't recall I'm pretty sure the flame
turned blue and that has always
intrigued me because you have to wonder
if that has anything to do with the
others yeah the ice at this point in the
show like everything that we're seeing
is technically has to do with ice and
fire like there's two separate beings
ice beings and fire beings and everyone
has to pick their side absolutely that's
something I was really interested in too
and you know when I initially wanted to
contact you to do a collab video
together I wanted to get your thoughts
on this because I am really curious what
Varys will do to cause his own death
like let's say he betrays Daenerys how
do you think he would do that do you
think he could go back to Cersei or
could it be something not even quite as
bad as that like maybe he will switch
his allegiance to John once he finds out
John is the true heir what do you think
I don't think Daenerys would be mad if
he changed his allegiance to John I
don't think she'll be mad about that I
think maybe what would cause there's his
death is
Varys would have to sell daenerys his
secrets she would have to change sides
to Circe you're on he would have to do
something that acts against the nurses
interest it could be something like just
there's just maybe trying to conspire to
put Sansa on the throne because Varys
has you know not really a big
relationship with thoughts of what
they're familiar with each other
Varys in the books is conspiring to put
a gun on the throne we don't have it
Aegon in the show the only a god we have
in the show is John I hope that he his
death doesn't come because of betrayal
but comes because of loyalty
speaking of Aegon and Varys has role in
the books now that the golden company
plot is being introduced into the show
do you think Varys is likely to switch
his allegiance to John if John ends up
taking the AEGON role from the books
with the golden company yes but I feel
like John and Danny are gonna be one
from here on out like they are Ice and
Fire
do you think everything is gonna be cool
when it gets revealed that John is the
true heir like do you think Daenerys
will be fine with that and when John
finds out he is related to Daenerys do
you think they will still have a good
relationship with each other I don't
think at first I think at first I mean
if I was to put myself in those shoes
I'd be like what the [ __ ] like I'd
probably need counseling but Daenerys
you know she she knows like Daenerys was
supposed to marry her brother she kind
of might be a little more accepting than
John is but that like when will John
find out John might not find out so the
very last episode that's definitely
possible and that's something I do want
to talk about when we were cortar Jon
Snow video let me ask you this though
let's say Melisandre returns which she
said she would so I do believe her but
if Melisandre returns and goes to the
north how do you think John and Davos
will react to that considering Davos
once are dead and John did say he would
have her killed if she were turned for
murdering princess Shireen I
don't think Melisandre will return to
the north as Melisandre because
Melisandre was on Dragonstone she could
have went to Davos and Jon while she was
on Dragonstone because she was under the
protection of Daenerys she could have
went and said whatever she wanted to
them but she was terrified of them she
didn't want to because she knew it would
it wouldn't have went over well
and she probably didn't want anyone
finding out what she did to princess
Shireen - yeah that - Davos is never
gonna get over he'll never accept
Melisandre yeah he'll never accept her
but I think that she's gonna beat the
old lady at least in the north I mean
they showed us that in the red woman
episode they should like we didn't have
a reason to need to see that so if
you're showing us that that must mean
we're gonna see this again and we need
to know who it is when we see that
person that's a really good point
because if we just saw a random old lady
during an episode we would have no idea
who she is
so are you confident Melisandre will
return to Westeros with a force from
volantis I am I feel like this is the
last season give us everything the
budget is huge the battle is gonna be
huge the battles are gonna be huge
there's no other reason for her to go to
volantis unless she's going to get some
potions or something like the reason for
her to go other than the fiery hand or
to bring more priests more of the people
that worship the red God to Westeros to
help fight this darkness because she
preaches of azor Ahai azor Ahai is
supposed to lead the fight he's not
supposed to do it myself he's just
supposed to lead that's true so maybe
she's gonna go gather more forces
she knows their need she already knows
what they you know their needs she knows
they don't have that many men she saw
the Battle of the bastard she knows how
many men they lost yeah and before Jon
exiled Melisandre from the north she
basically told him not to send her away
because she can help him
when the Great War she knows John has
seen her powers but what do you think
she meant by that
how can she help him win the war is that
gonna be getting men from volantis is
that making another shadow baby or
perhaps something else well when she
kept telling Stannis she could help him
it was usually about visions and magic
and shadow babies and stuff so it could
have been that it could have been you
know just advising advising John and
stuff which I think it's a good thing
that he sent her away because sending
her away leaves her no place to go to
help him other than to volantis but it
also brings up the question is that she
says she's her part is done and when
she's talking to Varys she says my part
is done I brought ice and fire together
but then she says cryptically that she
has to die in Westeros so that means
she's not completely done because she
plans on coming back and doing something
that will ultimately cause her own death
now does that mean she's gonna come back
and sacrifice herself or will she be
killed by Davos John or even Arya I
think Arya is the most likely killer of
no really I mean I feel like I don't
want to feel like that it's Arya that
will kill Melisandre because I don't
want Melisandre to die I think
Melisandre is like just a misunderstood
person anyway but I feel like they have
this Arya and Melisandre had this fate
like faded meeting what else do they
need to meet again for that's true
Melisandre said they would meet again
the only thing that makes me somewhat
skeptical of that though is when Arya is
at the house of black and white in
season 6 she recites her list to the
wife and when she does she only names
three people one her list
she didn't say Melisandre's name so I
wonder what that means now hmm yeah she
took the Hound off her list too
yes she did she actually took quite a
few names off her list and I don't know
if that is
stop laught whole or if they were taken
off for a reason beric Dondarrion and
Thoris of me are no longer on there
either the only names she mentioned were
Cersei the mountain and Walder Frey I've
been wondering if Arya thinks she's
never gonna see these people again or
did she just decide she no longer wanted
to kill them and of course another
possibility is the showrunners know
those characters are never gonna cross
paths again so maybe they just decided
to take the names off themselves
that could be true they could have just
like 86 the whole Melisandre and Arya
meet again but it could have been she
didn't want to lose herself in the house
of black and white in her book chapters
like she's kind of like she lies a lot
there she tries to lie anyway you saw in
the show she didn't put she had needle
she didn't get rid of needle so her
telling the waste the names that are on
her list is giving up you know who she
is maybe she's just didn't saying
because she just didn't want them to
know you know what now that you say that
that reminds me when Arya did recite her
list to the wave the wave said that's a
short list are you sure that's all that
is on your list and Arya said which name
would you like me to say or something
like that
I feel like though she won't kill
Melisandre if she sees Gendry first
yeah me too and I think she will see
ginjury first I'm kind of hoping we see
Gendry arrive in Winterfell in the first
episode yeah I'm hoping that for that
too I was confused
Chandru was at east watch right see I'm
not exactly sure I thought so but
somebody said when Jon was on the boat
getting his frozen coat removed
apparently ginjury was helping Davos
remove his coat I didn't notice that and
I never went back to check but that's
what some people told me in the comments
before okay okay cuz if Gendry dies at
east watch if Kendra died off-screen
Arya is gonna murder Melisandre no
Sandra's out of here oh man yeah I think
one way Melisandre could get back into
Jon's good graces is if
she shows up what the fiery hand and
ends up saving them during the battle
like let's say one of the battles
against the night King takes place in
the north if John and Daenerys would
start to lose that battle to the point
to where it looks like they could all
die
I think if Melisandre would show up with
the fiery hand and save them I think
John might give her a pardon although
Davos will never forgive Melisandre but
if she saved John Dany and everyone else
then John might be like alright well she
did save us so you can be pardoned do
you think it would be like a little
finger situation like Littlefinger shows
up with the Vale soldiers yeah I think
that's possible the show tends to do a
lot of that deus ex machina more people
get saved just in time so I wouldn't be
surprised if Melisandre shows up during
the battle and saves some people like
just as an example we could see a battle
at Winterfell then right as it's looking
like the night king is about to take
over Winterfell and kill everyone
that's when Melisandre could show up
with a thousand and one men from the
fiery hand who all have these Spears
with flames on the end and that could be
enough to shift the battle then you also
have to wonder if all of these men that
Melisandre could bring from the temple
would they all have powers of their own
- right and like what if they could they
become White's Melisandre is like a
magical being
she's hundreds of years old so can she
even become a white
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]